welcome back so in the last few lectures
we've been looking exclusively almost at
the linear system X dot equals ax okay
so this could be a high dimensional
state X some linear dynamics may be
linearized from a nonlinear system
around a fixed point and we have some
actuation plus bu so we have some
control knobs in you that we can affect
the system with and we know if the
system is controllable then we can
design this control law to arbitrarily
manipulate the system basically okay so
I want to just keep track of everything
we have X in our n we have you in our Q
okay so I have n States Q inputs and let
me just draw the sketch of the diagram
of what we've been doing okay so we have
our system this is our system and it has
been X dot equals ax plus B u we're
assuming that we can measure everything
about the state so our measurements Y
are equal to X they're equal for the
identity matrix times X so what's coming
out of here is just X and then the idea
is that there is some state feedback
some full state feedback u equals minus
K X that optimally stabilizes this
system okay so the input U and when I
say full state feedback what I literally
mean is I'm measuring the full state of
my system X I'm feeding that back into
my controller so my u equals some
constant matrix times my full state and
that's fed back as the input into my
system and so for example I can develop
this using the linear quadratic
regulator so I could develop this using
lqr and that would be optimal in some
cost function if I knew this full state
information X ok that's what we've been
doing so far and just to go one step far
if I plug in U equals minus KX into this
I get X dot equals ax minus B K X so
that's the same as X dot equals a minus
B K X okay so I have basically full to
manipulate the eigen values of this
system with closed-loop feedback to make
them anything I want and lqr is a
particularly good choice that balances
you know how aggressively I'm
stabilizing the system and how much
control expenditure how big this U is to
do it and so sometimes I'll call this K
R for my regulator my K R will be my
regulator okay that's what we've done so
far so where are we going and this is
going to get really interesting so in
real life I don't actually often have
access to my full state of my system so
for example on the inverted pendulum on
a cart maybe I don't want to measure all
four of my state variables maybe I just
want to have an encoder to measure the
theta position and then I ask myself the
question can I back out the full state
so in reality I don't always have access
to full state measurements I probably
only have access to some limited
measurements Y which equals some C times
X and in general Y is going to be in RP
so I'm going to have let me write this
over here or P I'm going to have P
measurements of my system so P might be
much much less than n so remember in
even if I had like a million dimensional
system I could still have full
controllability with one actuator one
column of B in many cases even if I have
a million dimensional system I can get
full estimation with one one row one
measurement one measurement of my state
okay and so that's going to be the name
of the game before we were looking at
the controllability controllability what
we call C
TRB of the a and B matrix now what we're
going to be looking at so the new thing
that we're going to be doing from now on
is looking at the observability of a and
C so there's this dual notion of the
observability and what's really nice is
that there's a why the what's really
nice about observability i'm going to
call this OBS v the observability of a
and c is that actually much of the
linear algebra of figuring out if i can
back out the full state from limited
measurements the linear algebra here is
almost identical to the linear algebra
here it's just transposed okay so it's
almost identical and we're going to work
through what that means and what the
implications are but controllability
meant can I steer the system anywhere
given some you what this means is can I
estimate any state any high dimensional
state X from a time series of my
measurements from my measurements Y of T
and so this is actually kind of
remarkable that in even in a high
dimensional system oftentimes I can
estimate that full state from very very
few measurements of my systems if I know
what the dynamics are if I know this a
matrix and a and C are observable and so
in that lab for example this is exactly
the same kind of rank of observability
AC equals end and the system is
observable so a lot of the the MATLAB
and the linear algebra we're going to
borrow from controllability but the
interpretation is a little bit different
so going back to this picture here we
would like to have full state
measurements of our system X because if
we can measure all the states of our
system we know an optimal full state
feedback controller really easy to get
and it works really really well okay in
practice we don't always have access to
the full state we have measurements Y
and so what we're going to be doing is
we're
going to not only develop a controller
we're also going to develop something
called an observer or an estimator so
that given why we're going to back out
what X is and we're going to use that as
a proxy for this linear quadratic
regulator so I'm just going to show you
what that diagram looks like and then
we're going to spend the next few
lectures working out what observability
means mathematically how you would
design that observer and then we're
going to put the two together okay so
now in a more realistic system I'm going
to have system okay but now it's going
to be X ax equals ax plus B u y equals C
X okay so I don't have I don't have
access to all of my measurements what is
coming out of here is now Y not X so
then what we're going to do is we're
going to develop something called an
estimator and in this case we're going
to use we're going to use the famous
Coleman filter but basically this is
just a full state estimator and it's
exactly what it sounds like
okay so I'll tell you what comes into
here in a minute but the output of this
calman filter or full state estimator is
an estimate of my full state X okay and
I'm going to call it X hat so it might
not be exactly X I might be some noise
or some disturbances but basically the
output of my estimator I take my
measurements Y and I'm going to estimate
the full state of my system which I can
then plug in to my optimal full state
feedback controller so now I'm going to
plug X hat in using lqr and that U is
going to get fed into my system okay now
there's a couple of catches here and it
just gets a little more complicated
because if I really want to estimate my
state X for my measurements Y I also
have to know how I've been kicking the
system because it's not independent from
you so I also have to take you and feed
that into my common filter
okay so Mike almond filter takes in
measurements of the system and what I'm
how I'm kicking the system and
essentially it's a dynamical system X
hat dot equals some new a matrix I'm not
going to write it all out right now but
it's a it's a dynamical system it's a
linear dynamical system that essentially
estimates this full state X hat it given
knowledge of y and u ok once we have
that estimate of X hat we can then
combine it with our our beloved lqr
controller and stabilize the system okay
so that's where we're going we're going
to take systems where we don't measure
the full state we're going to have to
build an estimator for the full state
and then we're going to use that in
conjunction with lqr
and what's really really interesting is
that the same optimal optimization
techniques to get lqr
are going to be used to get the optimal
calman filter so again there's this
duality between concern controllability
and observability I can use the same
linear algebra that I used to build my
lqr controller to build my optimal
column and filter and what's really
remarkable I'll show you this later is
that I can develop these separately in
isolation to each be optimal so I can
develop an optimal full state controller
I can develop an optimal full state
estimator and when I combine them the
combined system will also be optimal in
the same cost function so this is going
to be really cool we're going to
leverage everything we know about
controllability and lqr and eigenvalue
placement but now what we're going to be
doing is taking measurements and backing
out an estimate for what our full state
of the system is doing okay and this is
much more practical in the real world
sensors are expensive and you don't get
to measure everything so we're going to
have limited measurements to control our
system this is sensor based feedback and
it's much more realistic okay so next
time we're going to dive into
observability and then we're going to
develop these systems thank you